ophélie s'endort et commence à rêver
voyage dans l'époque des dinosaures
virée dans le future transformation en
sirène une histoire dessinée par carat à
partir des idées proposées par des
jeunes place à la création de la vème
planche j'ai eu l'idée que la baleine
wahaha là à la fin se transforme en
grenouille et que kara tu deviens une
guerrière amazon il faut que
graphiquement je trouve des astuces pour
aller plus vite
même s'il ya du décor même s'il ya
plusieurs personnages donc pendant que
moi je dessine e dessine aussi de leur
côté je leur fils parfois quelques
petits conseils à droite à gauche pour
que je puisse un petit peu aussi
s'amuser de leur côté depuis une
quinzaine d'années car a écrit des bd
bercé par des influences franco belge et
le style manga dans cet atelier il donne
des conseils aux jeunes présents
le dessin autour et plus du style bd et
que en fait le visage de la jeune fille
et plus du style manga
j'aime vraiment beaucoup de mongols
depuis que je suis petit somme plaisir
vraiment contrairement aux autres
dessins animés qui passe à la télé et du
cinéma jean aux orres pour le réseau des
médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'objectif est
de rendre ce moment participatif avec
l'encadrement d'un professionnel
d'autres animations sont prévues dans le
cadre du festival bébel sky jusqu'au 18
février prochain